The only thing I ever really wanted
in my life was to be a mother.
That's the one thing I didn't get to them.
It was 24.
I woke up one morning and my bed was
completely soaked and I thought I'd peed
the bed.
I was four and a half months pregnant,
but when I called the doctor, he had me
come in and my amniotic sac and broken,
I didn't know what to do.
I couldn't eat,
I couldn't sleep and I
couldn't stop crying because
nobody tells you when you're
young. There's a 20% chance that
you could have a miscarriage.
My marriage didn't work out.
A lot had to do with how hard it
is for a marriage to lose a child.
So that was my first miscarriage
and I moved to Mexico
and I got married again.
I got pregnant again
and I knew enough to double check
because I'd had a miscarriage.
So I went in and they told me that,
um,
I had what's called an incompetent cervix
and that just means that your cervix
doesn't stay shut.
That was pregnant for five months.
The doctor said to me
as I was miscarrying,
have you had an abortion?
Pretty much insinuating that maybe it
was my fault that I was having these
problems.
That was 1995 and in 1996 I got
pregnant again with my daughter,
feral, feral. Alma means wild soul,
and I was pregnant five and a half months.
Every time it got to be a little bit more.
So the next time when I went in
and I knew I was going to lose
Pharrell,
I refused to let the baby out until
they promised to let me see her.
I moved again and I was living in the
Caribbean and in 1998 I got pregnant with
Aiden and somehow I knew it
was a boy from the beginning,
so I had already named
Aiden means fiery one,
and my husband had already left.
By the time I found out it was pregnant,
he'd already decided he
wasn't going to stay,
even though I'd
already had three miscarriages and I knew
that being pregnant was a risk for me
and both physically and emotionally
I couldn't.
I couldn't not try.
When you're pregnant you
can't help but hope, hope
you imagine what your child will do
and the things that they'll have.
B and I didn't tell anyone I was pregnant
because I thought for sure that I
wouldn't be able to keep the baby when
the doctor told me that I should not work
and I refused and I thought that if I
didn't give everything of myself up and I
kept working,
that if it didn't work out
might not hurt so much
and I was six months pregnant and
I was getting my regular checkups.
I was excited
and the doctor let me know that
something was wrong with Aiden.
My son had a rare genetic disorder.
They'd caused his kidney's
not the function properly.
It was going to toxify my system and
there was a high risk that I would die.
I needed to terminate the pregnancy
because the baby was going to suffocate in
utero and I was dead.
I went to see a specialist
that I had seen before
and they told me the same thing.
He wouldn't be able to survive and
they just didn't even want me to leave.
They wanted me to just
take care of it right there
and I refused.
I didn't care.
I wanted so bad that there was
something that they could do
to save my son and I was
willing to die for that,
but I couldn't,
that wasn't going to fix the problem.
Okay.
It didn't matter what I was willing to
give up. My Mother didn't know what to do.
She was a nurse and she still
didn't know what to say.
So I left him,
take my stitches out
and they induced labor.
When I made the decision that I would
let the doctors do what they wanted,
I felt so guilty.
I felt
like I was giving up my child.
I don't really can't think
of anything worse to do.
I remember thinking that
I wish that my labor more,
I just wanted to feel something
because I felt so numb and Aiden was born
and they had forgotten to tell
me that he would be alive.
He was
considered a live birth,
so they had to wait
and you know,
do all the things you do to a new
baby and then they wrapped him up.
When they placed Aiden on my chest,
he was struggling and I heard his prayer.
It felt like funder to me.
It was definitely
wanted him to open his eyes so bad.
I want it to be able to look in her eyes.
No,
but he was loved. I need for life
for about an hour and 40 minutes.
He took his last breath.
I felt like my heart stopped and I had
him cremated and I feel back to the
Caribbean and I sat in the
closet in my room and cry.
There was nothing to do to come from me.
It's one of those things I'm like,
but there's nothing to be sad.
There's nothing that's going to make it
better for so many years afterwards I
would go to visualizations or meditations
or anything to try to be a better
person. A lot of times they'll
tell you to visualize your,
you know, your pelvic bowl, your girdle
as like this golden orb of light.
And for many,
many years what I imagined it was
bio waste and something gone rotten.
I guess that's how I thought of my womb.
I think maybe the truth is I
have never fully grieved hidden.
Maybe that's why I'm here today.
Almost 20 years later,
I've been very lucky.
I have a lot of nieces and nephews and
I run a nonprofit that provides arts
education to children,
and I get to use all my skills and
something I'm really passionate about.
So I came today to celebrate my
four children and honor them,
and maybe the owner,
the 10 years of my life
I spent invested in that.
Most people in my life don't even know
that I've been pregnant four times,
but every once in awhile
I get a mother's Day card.
Someone
who knows me and loves me,
and it's
beautiful
and painful at the same time.